&gt;&gt; With point slope form, we have one point that's fixed and then we'll plug in
the coordinates into this other point. 1 for the x and 2 for the y. Notice that
I'm always using parentheses when I plug in. That's because I don't want to make
a mistake with my negative signs. Since both these numbers are positive, I can
drop the parenthesis. And on the other side of the equation, we have our slope,
negative 3 halves. Now, I'm going to cross-multiply. Then, I carry out the
distribution. Negative 3 times x is negative 3 x, and negative 3 times negative
1 is positive 3. On the right, I have 2 y and I have negative 4. I've re-written
this line up here and now I'm going to solve for standard form. I want the
constants on the right, and the x and y on the left. If you got negative 3 x
minus 2 y equals negative 7, excellent work. Notice how every single term is
negative. Well, we could just multiply every term by negative 1 and make the
entire equation and all it's terms positive. So, an alternative answer would be
3 x plus 2 y equals 7. These are actually the same exact equation. This one has
just been multiplied by a negative 1.